("Dear Insecurity" by Brandy Clark)
♪ Dear insecurity ♪
♪ Oh, we meet again ♪
♪ Don't try to flirt with me ♪
♪ You're not really my friend ♪
♪ But you take up half this bed ♪
♪ You're livin' rent-free in my head ♪
♪ Oh, insecurity ♪
♪ You show up in my mirror ♪
♪ Point out the worst in me ♪
♪ You whisper in my ear ♪
♪ That my lips are way too thin ♪
♪ Too many miles on my skin ♪
♪ If I can't find a way to get you gone ♪
♪ Can we find a way to
get along, along, along ♪
♪ You're careless, and you're
cruel, and oh, you're mindless ♪
♪ Maybe you could try a little kindness ♪
♪ Instead of hurtin' me ♪
♪ 'Cause insecurity ♪
♪ This time feels like love ♪
♪ She's really sure of me ♪
♪ So, please don't mess this up ♪
♪ If you cut in on this dance ♪
♪ I may never get another chance ♪
♪ I'll never find a way to get you gone ♪
♪ Wish I could find a way to
know you're wrong, you're wrong ♪
♪ You're careless, and you're
cruel, and oh, you're mindless ♪
♪ Maybe you could try a little kindness ♪
♪ Instead of hurtin' me ♪
♪ Why you hurtin' me ♪
♪ Insecurity ♪
(gentle piano music)
(audience applauds)
- Best songwriter of our generation.
Give it up!
(audience applauds)
(indistinct)
(Kelly claps)
(audience applauding)
(indistinct)
Welcome to "The Kelly
Clarkson Show", everybody.
Give it up for my band, y'all,
and my wonderful, extraordinary
duet partner, Brandi Clark.
(audience applauds)
That was her single, "Dear Insecurity",
off her new self-titled album.
Grammy nominated.
(audience cheers)
She recorded it with Brandi Carlile.
It's Brandi's Squared event.
I am so honored she let
me sing on it with her.
I'm a huge fan.
All I do is word vomit
every time I'm around her
'cause I'm such a fan.
But I literally think that you are
the greatest songwriter of our generation.
You're so talented.